Hello, I am making this video for the parents of those children
who are
currently studying in high school, i.e.
starting from 6th or 7th class till
10th
class. This is not suitable for those who are
already studying in 11th or 12th.  If you are
studying in Plus Two then children, if you are
watching this video then definitely watch it but
please share it with your parents also. Hello parents,
I am going to make this video and discuss some important
things which may
sound a little bad.  But my hope
is that you will see it in the sense of a constructive criticism,
so let's start.
You know that right now the
placement season is going on in all the engineering colleges and it
is also going on in IT and
gradually you will start hearing like this.  There will already be
news coming that that child has
got a package of Rs 1 crore, that child has
got a package of Rs 2 crore, every day
some such news will keep coming, so if you hear this, it will
feel good to hear.
Who does not want to get such a package,
but this is a news outlet, this is a news
media, they do not always tell the whole story,
in what context is this a package of Rs 1 crore, a
package of Rs 2 crore and how many people are getting the
total?  All this is not discussed with the entire batch,
so at present all these are
not discussed, so what I
want to say in a clear way is that as soon as this
news is heard, many
parents get affected by it.  And
very soon they start sending their children, who are currently
in 6th and 7th class,
to coaching institutes. Now
sending them to coaching institutes costs a lot of
money, so it is a kind of investment. If there is
investment, then any business is involved
in investment.  When you invest in any investment,
you have the hope
that you will get some return of investment from that investment and some of it
you will
get something in return, then this is the thing that creates a problem
right from the root.  What is the
problem? Look, your children are
old enough to understand that their
parents have made an investment on them. The
entire tenor of this investment is
about 10 years old. How to see, they are
three or four years old in high school.  Year 6th, 6th to 10th class and
then Plus 2 which is a
very stressful situation with intense pressure, that is two years,
you have almost 6 years and then four or five
years in college, so the total is 10 years, so
this is the whole 10 years which  It is very
important that children live in a very kind of delicate situation. It is the
time of their growth. At this time they go through such high pressure
situations which may
not be good for them mentally but on
top of that, this  An investment always means that it will have to
bring a return.
It is always silent in the mind of the parents to bring that huge money package for
them, so this is
not a good thing, then
what kind of problems are there in this, see when you
send them for coaching.  It often
happens
that when you send them for coaching, you do
n't even know that your children
need this ability.
It sounds a bit bad to say but it
is true that this is a maths skill.  And science
is the ultimate competition, so this competition will
not be achieved by just investing money. Now, no matter
how hard the children work, no matter how much they
concentrate, they
need one ability, then this
ability.  In some children, they arrive very late,
in some their
interest is in a different line, so there
is no question of filling that capability, so when you send them without seeing all this and understanding it, then
that is a pressure situation.
In a coaching institute, when those people
study in such a competitive environment every day, there is a competition every day, and in the midst of it, and in which they do not have the interest, then
it is not good.
But from the opposite side, let us
assume that your children adjust, they start
performing a little bit better
and by adjusting a little bit, they
ultimately become Plus Two well. The coaching for Plus Two
is very good.  The person under pressure has
coaching, does that too somehow and goes
to his dream institute. If it is
called dream institute then he
goes to any IIT or any old IIT, but it would be
wrong to forget that maybe if he had not done it like this
then some people would have achieved their normal high.
Had he remained in school, he would have been able to explore
some other abilities of his, be it B in
painting or B in literature, this is an
opportunity, meaning he did
not get it and had he gone to coaching, he would have never
explored it.  If he didn't do it, then it's okay, let's ignore this too.
Now that he has reached
IIT, now see what is his position now after getting into IDS
or getting into any good engineering college
and what is
his 10 year journey.  These are the people in the
last phase of the year, three-four years,
four-five years,
these are children, but after working
so hard from high school, they have
endured so much pressure and there
is a lot of freedom in the engineering institute, which means no one can speak.  It is
not that much, we teachers
sometimes scold us a bit
but we cannot see it like parents do
and in coaching institutes, what we
do like a regimented soldier
is also not done as
you know in any university.  If it happens then there is a lot of
freedom, so finally they get this
freedom, sometimes they misuse it a little
and even if they
don't misuse it, it is not that they are
doing anything bad, but they study with concentration.  If you are
not doing it, then it
is just because you have attained salvation and have come to
engineering institute. This type of
mentality is there in many children
and why should it be there because they have been
bearing so much pressure from such a young age,
now there is some relief.  If we want to do
such a thing then we understand such a thing but this is such an age,
such is the situation of the universities and
institutes
that this is the time to enter into the actual competition
and in this, if those
people put in all their efforts, then this will help them.
So a bad thing happens, a bad thing happens, meaning if
we look at it, we say that ours
are good, ours are good,
but such children generally become like a medium doing ours, it is okay, that is, it is okay,
anything is fine, something like this.  The meaning of this
type of taking up a job and doing something else can be
seen that the children who
come out of college at the age of about 223 years are
not even 25 yet, so it means that the
overall age is quite young but at that 25
Within a year, I have taken kind of retirement, I have started
working from life,
everything is going well, but from life, I mean
round part, kind of, it is fine, it will work, it will
work, if it is of this type, then it is a bad thing,
do as much good as you can.  Even if they could have, if they had
not studied in the competition from such a young age, they would
not have done that well.
Although they actually have the ability,
because they are tired, we should
not forget that initially
they had understood that mummy.  Papa had made
investment
and there was no return on it, that is,
not everyone understands the package of one crore two crores,
they understand it well, so
it causes a lot of frustration, that means
many children have to suffer all this frustration.
If so, this is also the reason why
they take a kind of retirement that it is
okay, the original dream did
not come true, what Mahai Bapa had hoped did
not happen, so anything goes, this is also the
reason for having such a mentality.  But
despite all this, I would say that if it
means that such children are
getting any kind of job, then it is okay, even if it is
not a package of one crore or two crores, but
they are getting some decent jobs and they are
working for their life.  We
are living normally, I will still say that this is a
success story, we will keep
it in the success column in our account of life,
but you look at it from the opposite side, there are
many such children
in coaching institutes who year after year
Meaning, year after year they keep trying
but they are not able to make it, they do
not get JE and
ultimately they go to such a college from
which their dream is far from coming true
and that investment is
far away from getting returns.  If they are not even able to make a good career,
then see, in such a situation,
those people have already lost their precious time, that is,
in high school, when they could have had
different abilities which
could have emerged, then those people
He did not get a chance to explore,
so right now he is neither doing well in engineering nor has
he developed the ability to do anything else,
which could have been done but has not been done, so it is a very mediocre
life, less than Medicare.  They have to spend
a lot of time, which is very, very
frustrating, so the thing is that
year after year, they are trying to
hold on to the shadow of a dream
which was not their dream.  Your dream
was there, it is a second hand dream for him,
so the meaning of his dream, which
was a possibility, has been completely destroyed,
so maybe he would have gone into literature and
done something, okay then all this will never happen.  When this
happens, it creates a lot of frustration
and we have been seeing this every year.
Faculty
members, it is a very sad thing and you can
see it by taking a small example. In India, we
know people who are cricketers.  Meaning, those who are
in the national team,
they have a lot of wealth, they have a
lot of fame in their name, they are very
rich and famous, they are just
like film stars, yet despite this, you all know
that if there is a special person among your children.  There
is no ability in batting and bowling, in
cricket, everyone
plays cricket. Nowadays in India, many people are
doing something else too, but many
children do play cricket, so
despite this, it is not that you all play your
children.  We just put them in Cricket Coaching
Academy, if any child is
showing some special ability or is
showing special interest, only then will you put him. It is
not that all of you are having dreams,
okay, everyone has some such dreams.  Mom and
Baba believe that their children
will become Virat Kohli or some big cricketer
but this does not mean that they will not
invest money in it, so if you are not investing money in it then
without thinking anything and without
seeing whether your children have some special
ability.  Also, why would you
invest money in it in class six to seven, this is
my question because see,
ultimately what it is, whether it is JE or
entrance examination, it
is ultimately like an athletic competition of maths and science, neither in this  It is
not achieved just by hard work, some
ability is required, some special interest is also
required and I assume that for the sake of success,
no special ability is required, it is achieved only
by training because
all the children who come are students.  I mean,
not everyone is at genius level,
not everyone comes with special talent,
we know this very well that they
come only because of coaching, so you
will think why not your child too,
but  What is good about them is that ultimately they
become good through medium education, but ultimately they are
not that good, so as an alternative,
if you wait for some time and instead of
sending them for coaching in six and seven,
see what all the talents emerge in them.
What a special ability he is
showing, he is showing it in painting also,
so if you think, are you ready to invest so much money
in a coaching institute, meaning
engineering coaching, for engineering entrance
coaching? Now if that means half or
one third.  There is also a student who is
showing some ability, maybe
in painting or maybe in literature.
If you invest even one third of his money in him,
then imagine how far he
can progress compared to the
rest of the country.  In whatever country, children may be
showing potential in whatever ways,
but their parents may not be investing
in them, but if you do, then
how far can your child progress,
how many opportunities can you give them.  It is a
matter of thinking and seeing, this is my
wish, I request you to wait a
little, as I am
saying again and again, and please do not read into the comparison
that his son is fine, his daughter
is already showing something special.  That if
someone is showing special abilities in Maths and Science,
then those people have sent him for coaching, then without seeing
anything, you should also send your children to do such
comparison, it will never be good,
so think a little and see, I have told you something about me.  I have
experience as a faculty
member here at IT Kharagpur.
I have been seeing every year whatever is happening
with the children. I am
speaking only on the basis of that direct practical experience,
so think again and look at the
coaching.  Before sending it, thank you and
my best wishes to all of you, with your
children and with all of your families.